yo what's up this is Samuel Leeds and
I'm actually in Miami right now and this
I just came to life for a week I'm with
my brother business partner and CEO of
property investors UK hangout and you
know what I just want accessible things
we've learned so much this week we've
been with Grant Cardone did some
mentoring with him which was just
absolutely insane and my mind is just
bellowing because we've been around
multi-millionaire people like Grant
Cardone and others our room was about
Emmis been 400 people everyone in the
room millionaire yeah 400 millionaires
and then we had one-on-one with grants
which was just insane and he was trying
to get us to buy big deals in Miami and
stuff like that so why don't you share a
couple of the learning points number one
is always give yourself time to go away
like man when you're working just always
in that you're working in the business
managing properties Burien houses doing
the same old thing what happens is you
can suppose become stagnant now my
business don't get me wrong
working with Russia like so it's not
it's not particularly stagnant but going
away and having time to think and just
rethink your business plan think bigger
brainstorm
listen with someone as well I mean we
would literally I know we went our way
but every single evening we were sounds
like 2:00 a.m. we're just talking coming
to ideas so shows as well I spent a lot
of money on education and so does well
so like we've spent just this week we've
spent $200,000 so about 160,000 pounds
on education going on programs get a
mentor ring finding people that are more
successful than we are and then just
saying hey you know what could I do
better in my business that's what it is
you know that is fantastic I've spent
over a million pound on my personal
education in the last five years now
1.25 million pound you know on my own
education because I really believe that
the bigger you become the bigger you are
the bigger your bank will be and
property investing is the second best
investment the best is always yourself
because no one can take that away
massive believer in if you put a pound a
pound in a slot machine and two pounds
come out you're going to keep putting
more money in the slot machine and it's
the same when you invest in yourself as
long as you take action on that then
you're just gonna keep growing it's one
of the reasons while I'm so successful
and while I've been so successful what
do you think of that bro
I totally agree when you when you when
you invest yourself you might so you're
doing this stuff anyway
so if you can learn bit to make your
tweaks in your business and your product
or whatever it is you know you can save
a lot of money yeah I can make a lot of
money yeah because small things like a
big difference and the bigger that you
know them especially the bigger
businesses as well and more than one
little tweak like when I'm at the
airport I'm looking at box you know the
books of a sale and Grant Cardone said
this is well I sometimes just the title
of a book you can look at interest and
then you can apply that and it can make
you a lot of money a little tweak a
little idea a little Golden Nugget
that's what I'm happy to jump on a plane
to go to Miami for a week just to get
those little golden nuggets but this we
can be more than golden your biggest
take by this week I think the biggest
takeaway this week was so many so many
biggest one I would say while you think
about that I'm gonna give another one
but you think about laughing all I'm
gonna say as well when you just spend
time give yourself time to think it's
good to get mentors get people to give
you information but sometimes mere us
we're just like man I just need an hour
of my own just the process and write
down what my application of this
information is going to be because
information is fantastic but without
implementation it's pointless so so I
think another thing as well as if you
haven't got any money and you think an
icon invest in myself I've got I've got
I got any money at all to do that I
can't go on the programs well you can
just buy a book and sit in the sunshine
on a hill for an hour and a half and
just think and just thinking alone and
just planning or talking to peers
talking to people that are doing what
you're doing that appears and having
sounding boards
the phones worn so hopefully we've got
now enough time to think about it
biggest [ __ ] on the planet I have okay
Lisa it's big for me I'm not sure this
big fella but the biggest for me would
be we use a lot of our money to invest
back into profit we also use longer than
to invest in education where I think we
should be spending a lot more money is
actually investing in our business
there's many more growing growing the
marketing we spend pretty much no money
on marketing I've got a massive
following on YouTube and there the
different sides pretty much all of that
is all organic is if we don't spend much
money on marketing without so much money
on the business why do boys the
importance number on the business
because if you if you want to grow the
business you might spend money on the
business investing it's the same as
investing in yourself but you want to
grow yourself you're investing and
probably more grow your portfolio yeah
invest in your business spend money on
marketing you grow your business you
know some people in property investment
world could be cheapskates
because what they can do is that they'll
put all the money into a property but
then actually the managing of that the
furniture the systems that try and cut
corners but when you just want to be I
think one of the things that I've
learned as well is just be abundant
being in Miami one of the most beautiful
cities on the planet and money flows you
don't miss least or money up you want
you need to flow yeah we've spent a lot
of money this week now luckily it's all
tax deductible because we're here on a
business trip but when you spend a lot
like even just on the airplane
if you always think in small mind I'm
gonna go the cheapest to see and I'm
gonna I'm gonna go I'm gonna go to the
restaurant I'm gonna get the cheapest
wine and what happens is you've you've
bit you think small more in delay and
you think you're come going to look at
it is from a saving what is yeah and you
got you know the more if you want to
make more money you need to bring it up
and spend in order to open it up to
bring more and rich people don't save up
money rich people invest money and they
let it follow through them so super poor
it's been an incredible week I'm about
to jump on my plane we're going to
different different parts of the world
now you have to Ireland
I'm going to England we'll hook up back
when we're in the UK but guys let us
know your thoughts let us know what when
was the last time you invested in
yourself when was the last time you
spent money on your education when was
the last time you put time aside to just
think and to plan into brainstorm
comment below and let me know and I look
forward to seeing you next time peace
out and I thank you for watching